in this video we'll be talking about
fluroquinolones fluroquinolones are DNA
guid inhibitor and they antibiotics used
against broad spe uh broad spectrum of
bacteria be it gram negative or gram
positive so these fluroquinolones can
inhibit DNA gyas enzyme or topoisomer 4
enzyme this is how they work and when
these enzymes are inhibited that lead to
abrogation of DNA replication process
and this leads to accumulation of double
strand braks in the DNA that lead to a
bacterial death now if the bacteria
cannot replicates it DNA it has double
stranded break so obviously the bacteria
will die once it cannot amplify itself
it is
harmless so in order to understand how
fluroquinolone work we have to
understand the mechanism of DNA G action
so this is how a DNA gas enzyme would
look like it has two major subunit gu B
and gu a so so here I mean it's
important to understand that it belongs
to Topo isomerous 2 family that means it
can introduce double stranded DNA
break and also it introduce negative
super coils which relieve the torsal
strain during replication that is why it
is important for processes like
replication or gene expression I mean
transcription so for bacterial
metabolism and growth this enzyme is
really
essential so guide B portion of guide B
portion of that DNA guy raay holds one
section of the double stranded DNA and
then chops off another strand in this
case the black strand is chopped off so
double stranded DNA break is introduced
this part is important later on the
other strand that means the red strand
would be passed through this uh double
stranded DNA breakage and later on the
double the black strand would be
eventually
religated after re religation the enzyme
disengage and ultimately we end up
getting one negative super coil which is
added to the DNA right now now the thing
is in case of uh the fluocinolone
antibiotics the fluocinolone bind to the
guide a subunit and it prevents the
repairing of the double stranded DNA
break that means it allows the enzyme to
engage with the DNA create the double
stranded DNA break but when this
particular antibiotic is present the
double stranded DNA break cannot be
repaired this is how it inhibits that
enzyme so obviously double stranded DNA
breaks accumulate in the DNA and that
inhibits processes like replication
transcription which are very essential
for bacterial growth and multiplication
so obviously bacteria
dies that explains how fluocinolone can
act now be G gram negative ped gram
positive every bacteria need to amplify
increase their number and that cannot
happen when we give flurinol
antibiotic so that is why it's
antibiotic of choice for many infections
like respiratory tract infection urinary
tract or GI tract infection here are
some prescribed format of fluroquinolone
cof
fline is widely used for urinary tract
infection skin infection and GI
infection all fline is mainly used for
urinary tract and GI infection there are
others like lyine Moxy fline Etc
now generally there are not too much of
side effect but adverse side effect can
be with any medicine so it has to be
taken with the consultation of a doctor
there could be drug interaction so one
has to think uh clearly about when to
consume the
drug and lastly these days there is a
worrisome thing which is the resistance
against fluroquinolone and that could
lead to a big problem in near future so
I hope this was informative enough see
next
video